ah
[Música]
cientos de personas salieron a celebrar
acá en el centro de washington la
victoria de joe biden con todo tipo de
pancartas de bailes y de música incluso
hubo mariachis y la celebración fue
hasta entrada la madrugada rompa por su
parte ha estado muy activo en las redes
sociales en twitter ha retwitteado
mensajes de simpatizantes y de senadores
que pues siguen alegando el fraude en
estas elecciones uno de ellos es el
senador por carolina del norte
lindsey graham quien le recomienda al
presidente no conceder la victoria
porque según él varias personas que
estaban muertas terminaron votando en
varios estados del país en esta línea se
vienen entonces demandas litigios en
michigan en pensilvania en georgia en
arizona y en nevada como lo ha informado
la campaña del presidente don 8
[Música]
aquí en miami la población latina está
profundamente dividida ante los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales en el estado de florida
ganó la candidatura republicana pero en
las grandes zonas urbanas como el
condado de miami dade west ham beach
tampa orlando jacksonville los
demócratas salieron victoriosos los
simpatizantes hispanos de donald trump
muchos de ellos cubanos y venezolanos
están convencidos al igual que el actual
presidente que ha habido fraude en estos
comicios y que la justicia debe
intervenir porque según ellos en
realidad el que ha ganado ha sido el
mandatario republicano además aseguran
que si el caso llega a la corte suprema-
los jueces de mayoría conservadora
darían la razón a trama esa opción sin
embargo tiene muy pocas posibilidades de
convertirse en una realidad según varios
expertos consultados por france a 24 en
el otro lado están los demócratas que
este fin de semana salieron a las calles
del centro de la ciudad están
satisfechos con el resultado y creen que
la llegada a la casa blanca de joe biden
y su fórmula vicepresidencial kamal
permitirá unir a la sociedad
estadounidense que actualmente está muy
polarizada por las políticas impulsadas
por donald trump
[Música]
este fin de semana ha sido un festejo
casi continuo en la ciudad de san
francisco y es que esta ciudad es una de
las más liberales sino la más liberal de
un estado ya de por sí bastante
demócrata aquí en california además san
francisco ha sido uno de los opositores
más feroces al gobierno de trump donde
se han dado junto opta con washington
las protestas más multitudinarias de
estos cuatro años de gobierno de hecho
también san francisco es una de las
ciudades digamos fetiche de donald trump
la menciona muy continuamente asegurando
que es una especie de pesadilla liberal
de hecho otra ciudad donde también se ha
celebrado de manera continua y donde
todavía continúan las celebraciones es
en la ciudad de auckland justo enfrente
de san francisco y es que esta es la
ciudad que vio crecer a kamala harris la
futura vicepresidenta y que también le
vio dar sus primeros pasos políticos
[Música]